stations thank you thank you it's  actually my first time to reach the  quarter finals after playing so much  it's good to know how it feels like  and what a dramatic way to to do it  winning on most uh win situation in the  last round and also Anisha losing how do  you feel  yeah I mean I'm thrilled that I'm in  quarter finals and actually I it was  completely unexpected in fact I had  already made some plans for tomorrow  which was not related to chess so I was  not expecting it so thanks to Arjun you  know give me this chance I was wondering  because I know you guys have a great  team spirit in the Indian team if you  guys had been chatting before that final  round if you were hoping that he would  uh give the help that you needed  no no we did not chat but of course I  was hoping that he would uh you know I  mean it was not in my control so I was  just  um thinking about my game mostly